watching someone else gamble big money
is kind of like watching porn yeah yep
it's the same it's like oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude I seriously you're
crazy dude and then when it's over
you're like why didn't we why did we do
that oh
it's like how do you objectify her like
yeah uh speaking of gambling
so you had a crazy weekend
uh shout out to this man train wrecks
for having big so okay
there's a twitch thing there's a lot of
context here but basically for a while
now
people have been just gambling uh
uh via I don't know how
I don't want to butcher it I want to get
it wrong I believe it's like crypto and
then converted real cash but it's like a
digital Casino okay I've seen yeah xqc
was doing this for a while and then he
stopped yeah so he felt weird about it
he got like addicted maybe yeah that
much I don't know okay I know train
wrecks though had a stream
where he started uh
let's see today's Wednesday so this is
yesterday so yesterday morning I I see
that he's live and he's gambling and I
think he had started the the day before
it was night time he typically streams
at night so I think at this point he was
13 hours into his stream okay hey and he
was at 230k at the beginning of the
stream but at that point he had been
down I guess I don't know the exact
timeline but so by the time I'm in
he is uh he's got about 80k okay
he's down yep and how did these guys
have so much money to gamble just wait
so this boy train is like he's playing
this game book of shadows and the way it
works is it's like a five column slot
and you you're trying to get you're
trying to line up three books okay like
Book of the Dead Books Okay and then
when you do that it triggers a bonus I
know I know how that's right [ __ ] works
right I'm just saying forever
I'm just saying this for anyone who
doesn't it's like it's funny because
like every song every time someone comes
up like one of the girls are like I
don't understand how slots works or
anyone else that has never played a slot
it's like is this you just need three
bonuses that's what you need and then
you win big yeah so he's hunting uh
there's a picture of a girl and if you
get five of her you win a million okay
and at the point that I joined the
stream he had triggered the girl's face
I think it was like 12 or 13 times
already so he kept getting close getting
close
so but you need five of them you need
five of them yeah so he did three or he
did four I see he's riding the wave and
he he would step away to to juice he was
like I'm gonna juice up I'm like what
the [ __ ] is it and I see little emotes
of nostrils and sugar
okay
so he'd step away from the cam do
cocaine no he's juicing up okay okay
and then he'd come back and then and he
would do that when like he'd get the
three books and if it landed on the girl
so I'm fully drawn in this might be like
a bad thing to promote but I'm like
because it's not my money but I'm like
this is crazy right because he's doing
like a thousand dollar spins
because he you know he would like lock a
column whatever
so I don't think like I was pretty I'm
watching I understand why it's so like
um what's the word like controversial
not controversial but like you're you're
encapsulated by this oh yeah because
it's like depraved gambling this guy's
doing drugs I just can't believe how
many you know 13 14 hours into the
stream I'm like this is Rock Bottom [ __ ]
but like in the most addictively no in
the most crazy way dude he's got this
Skyline View like penthouse
I'm like this dude is Living Like a Wolf
of Wall Street moment this is wow yeah
yeah so I watched for an hour but could
very quickly be Rock Bottom is what I'm
saying right this could go south which
what was great was people were like
donating they're like oh man you're
helping curbing my itch to whatever he's
like good man don't [ __ ] do it even
if I hit today doesn't [ __ ] matter
you're gonna get crushed everyone gets
crushed so
I'll pull myself away I'm an hour I'm an
hour and I'm like I gotta stop
I go back
and I'm bringing this up because you
mentioned you know you mentioned going
to the casino and I'm like oh this train
story is kind of interesting and I'm
telling Luke and Kyle like we should
bring this to the show when we go up and
and as like we end our meeting and some
minutes after
I go over to a stream and I just see his
bankroll is one million two hundred some
thousand I'm like what the [ __ ] and he
hit it play it
so six pins
please
oh my God
ly trained you did it yes
yes
finally yes yes
what a goddam cry
that's so funny how is this legal
congratulations how is this legal I
can't speak to that
and what's crazy is leading up to that
he hit one where he won 160k and to
anyone else that'd be like bro
that's it this thing like you're almost
back to break even yeah you're not
getting higher that's it and he's like
no yeah but if he quit though he never
never he never would have hit them and
that's a lesson of gambling you just got
it's like you stick it out until you hit
because everyone eventually hits that's
not Financial advice that's not
Financial advice but bro I'm kidding but
isn't that kind of what this is teaching
all of the people that watch this I mean
dog whatever like I I mean who cares
about the morality of it this
[ __ ] won a million dollars live
that blew my mind I was like that's
crazy yeah what a crazy
and he banked A Milli and he kept going
and I don't know where he ended up oh no
he's probably still got tons of money
left no he's totally good yeah he's up
yeah he's up up well I mean congrats
congrats yeah that's insane that's what
I'm saying congrats what I'm basically
saying is I actually do the morality of
it is interesting to me because it's
like this wasn't a thing and all of a
sudden Steve will do it this guy xqc
whatever got like addicted to it yeah
like these guys are spending 13 hours on
slots like the reason why Vegas is so
like hardcore about checking IDs and all
that [ __ ] is that like that behavior
when you're sitting in front of a slot
machine with two other guys and you guys
are just like come on come on man [ __ ]
dude who's that 100 let's put it let's
feed this thing let's go I'm touching
the screen like there's a little like
animal on one of them and I was petting
the animal for good Juju because we did
that one time and it hit I'm like this
is the only meant to be seen by the
security camera guy yes you know yeah
he's the only one meant to see this not
50 000 kids watching this guy do this
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah like
it's like crazy like imagine if like
every Vegas slot machine had like fish
eye cameras in them just go straight to
the lobby and people were just like
standing in the lobby watching you just
like just be an idiot yeah I don't know
why Vegas hasn't done that yet that
sounds actually kind of [ __ ] you
should you should actually be able to
sit down in a slot machine and then just
scan a QR code that has your stream uh
your stream key yeah and then you just
go you just go live on Twitch right
there from the seat just [ __ ] what is
up guys I'm here at Harrah's in South
Lake Tahoe and today we're going for it
bring it in and they just bring a
[ __ ] wad of cash yeah like and these
machines are old school so we get to see
the coins come out
14 hours into it I'm gonna go re-juice
yeah yeah eight gin and tonics later
you're like keep waiting for the drink
it's not coming I'm almost out at 5am
I'm just kind of trying to doing smaller
bets waiting for the drink lady because
she's not coming have you seen her did
you see her anywhere I just swear I just
saw her the crap sir please come over
here but she hasn't been over here in
like an hour
who's got the hunters are all gone
there's an ATM could you hit it because
I'm already past mine yeah already
overdraft yeah past my limit
so yeah I'm just saying gambling like
brings out the absolutely brings out the
dog in you yeah though it's fun but no
one is meant to see it so here's what's
craziest and you know what I found out
afterward is this dude rosstein so in
the same day
this is what's really crazy that's what
I'm saying why there's so many dudes
doing this bruh I don't know I can't
speak to it
so I'm not saying much I'm not trying to
poo poo it I just like you know I don't
know
but so this dude roshn before we played
what he hit
I had like come like couple people made
threads about how they thought you know
he had these big wins that people were
speculating were fake you know yeah
that's another thing is that you don't
you don't know for sure if these
websites aren't just paying these guys
yeah you don't know if it's like okay
within some period you're gonna nail it
but we'll just bankroll you
but just playing on stream we'll
bankroll you well that is a great seg
for all the um you know
the save the kids coin scam which we can
talk about afterwards I didn't watch the
coffee video about it okay I need to I
need a little a summary so good that way
all right so watch this do Rush thing
watch this hit this is crazy man because
I've been spinning food party for seven
dollars soon without
going down
um oh
[Applause]
2.5 million
oh my God what on what an old base game
let me play it right now oh my God I see
this this is his voice is stuck at that
decibel now yeah
what game oh that big [ __ ]
I don't know what it was called
Ola pig say got hurt I don't know
that's good Postmates calls hello leave
it at the door
2.5 million
wow 2.5 million dollars that [ __ ] no
that morning or are you even able to
gamble at the at that stake I don't know
steaks whatever you know so that I think
was the primary call out was
bro how are you betting so relatively
small and winning so massive yeah so so
yeah so there's that and then that
screenshot I sent you of Steve will do
it who does this but he doesn't rub it
or whatever yeah rub it rub it who also
like rub it like flies them around on
private jets and stuff like that yeah
right to me it's sometimes like a is
this some kind of backhand deal yeah you
know that's kind of I don't know if it
is it's like all this stuff just seems
kind of shady to me the gambling stuff
because it's like gambling just is Shady
in itself yeah well it's meant to [ __ ]
people over you know so
I can't man I know this is a lot of just
like whatever
so now you have this level like of
normally people watch other people
gamble and they start gambling with them
you know what I'm saying but now it's
like you have this level
on top of her underneath of gambling
it's just people giving this guy money
to keep gambling yeah that's [ __ ]
weird yeah it's either that or
you know I think people's take on it is
when they watch Twitch streamers do like
a guy like train you know you have to
give credit to guys like train and even
xqc and and all them like they are
definitely committed to creating content
and making themselves like
entertainment you know yeah like
they do 14-hour streams not consistently
but I know xqc was doing like 11 12 a
day
you're gonna start to just do some [ __ ]
because like after games and reacting to
videos it's like all right yeah
let's do something crazy yeah no what
I'm what I'm saying is that it makes
excellent content and I honestly would
watch this yeah what I'm saying is it
feels like regulation hasn't or like
twitch rules haven't caught up to this
yet yeah it's like something about this
should be not good oh totally yeah like
you should be 21 to even watch this yeah
probably right yeah you should be an
adult I guess you can watch people play
poker online but that's different
yeah I don't think it's the same as like
slot machines where poker you have to
like go in person yeah no you can play
online I don't know yeah you guess you
can I used to do that yeah but you have
to lie and say your age is older right
yeah that's all you do
I think it's just more like yeah with
the internet
it's you're definitely gonna have kids
watching and it's like what degree of
responsibility do you have to that yeah
and I mean like probably signing up for
one of these crypto gambling sites isn't
that hard just use a VPN yeah and you
fund it with ethereum which every kid is
doing that anyway the funniest part is
only kids know how to get to these sites
that's what I'm saying like an adult
trying to figure out how to use one of
these [ __ ] crypto websites uh so you
get what what is a what is a VPN yeah
great question Dave uh our sponsor for
today
so yeah Dad coming over what are you
playing Fruit Ninja or something what's
on there shut the [ __ ] up I'm down 100
I'm down 100 I'm down 100 Grand right
now dad I have to do it I mean the
[ __ ] trenches right now Dad shut up
shut the [ __ ] up get the drink lady
around as you come around yet drink lady
yeah you're [ __ ] whatever it is your
wife or whatever
I don't know I crawled out of her [ __ ]
or something I don't know dude just just
get me a drink yeah I'm 100K in I had to
do a flash loan with tether to [ __ ]
Doge baby coin it's literally the value
of this house dad you know what I'm
talking about you know this one down
right now you don't even understand when
I hit 18 I'm [ __ ] out of here this
place is a dump I bought a place in the
Caribbean that rules the dad's like oh
sorry yeah sure so yeah all right have
fun with your little games your kids and
their computers eh I'm gonna go trade
stocks
make some real money
in the market today this kid's a
billionaire a literal billionaire
funny I've done a hundred dollars
in the market yeah 400 loss
he's sweating kid eating peanut butter
and jelly 400.
that I prop bet 400 while I'm playing
poker
I bet 400 on what the suits are going to
be coming out of the digital deck
grow the [ __ ] up 400.
[ __ ] so that's baby [ __ ]
I'm trading I'm trading [ __ ] coin
literal [ __ ] coin yeah